hi and welcome to alerting in cloud
monitoring my name is Rory and I'm a
product manager for cloud monitoring and
I'm joined by Syed who is a software
engineer who also works on cloud
monitoring so today we're going to talk
about how you create alerts what types
of metrics are available to alert on
we'll delve a little bit into the metric
and resource model in cloud monitoring
and we'll show a couple demos that
present different alerting concepts so
cloud monitoring is part of the cloud
operations suite at Google use core
infrastructure power is not only Google
cloud but all of internal Google so you
can build your operations workflows with
confidence on top of our cloud ops
products you might be familiar with the
term staff driver that was previously
the name for the monitoring product in
Google cloud we've since rebranded to
Google Cloud monitoring just to further
emphasize that we are the primary
monitoring and operations tool suite of
tools for all of Google Bob so you can
find a learning by going to the
hamburger menu in the upper left-hand
corner of the cloud console clicking it
scrolling down to the operations section
selecting monitoring and selecting
alerting in alerting you'll find the
ability to create alert policies you'll
see incidents that have been created
from alerts and you'll also see
notification channels which let you
route alerts to the correct person or
system so what is an alert policy alert
policies let you define a set of
conditions that will generate a
notification whenever that event is
triggered the notification can
optionally contain documentation and
metadata to provide additional
information to the person receiving the
alert alert notifications can be sent to
a variety of channels including email
SMS / painter Beauty web hooks pub/sub
and more so to create a new policy you
cook the quickly create alert policy
button and you add a condition so as you
can see here the first option you have
is to select your resource or metric
type so that begs the question in what
types
metrics are available to alert on all
Google cloud services emit a variety of
metrics that includes compute engine GAE
cloud sequel pretty much all of your
surfaces so there's a good selection of
metrics to choose from there are also
different types of metrics for example
custom metrics these are application
specific metrics that you define and
collect to capture information that the
built in GC key metrics cannot so these
can be engineering or business metrics
for example account of returning user
checkouts and e-commerce system can also
collect log based metrics which are
based on the content of log entries for
example the number of log entries that
contain a particular message or you can
even extract latency or other
information reported in your log entries
cloud monitoring and logging also have
agents available that allow you to
collect a range of metrics they are not
covered by a GC peak or metrics that
includes for example memory usage disk
allocation etc and lastly you can
collect uptime metrics which are
produced by uptime checks which send
probes from six different regions
worldwide to monitor your webpages your
api's and your services and they emit
metrics for lively than liveliness
latency and several other features that
you can alert on we also support a broad
range of metrics both for other clouds
and for the most popular open and closed
source applications so no matter what
applications you're running or whatever
structure you're on Google Cloud
monitoring is able to support you both
for monitoring and alerting
so we're gonna talk a little bit about
the metric and resource model I'm gonna
gain it over t cited in cloud monitoring
every time series is identified by two
things the metric and the resource the
resource is what you are trying to
monitor it can be a virtual machine it
can be a load balancer it can even be
something as abstract as a service
endpoint or a URL the metric is how you
were trying to make that measurement
something like request count or latency
or something bespoke to you like number
of customers that are using a certain
resource from that ID you will get a set
of time series that's what's shown here
on top this is the raw data for CPU
utilization across multiple projects and
instances in different regions the first
thing to do in cloud monitoring is to
align the data this way all the data is
regularly sampled and is a summarization
of the or our data point in each window
in this case we've chosen to do a line
next older which means for each window
we take the most recent point and move
into one two three or or other minute
boundaries now every time series is a
line so we can aggregate them we can
aggregate all of them into one time
series now we have the mean CPU
utilization across our entire fleet
often we also want to break this mean
utilization as a summary down in this
case by region and now we have regional
meeting evil ization both alignment and
reduc and group bys are going to be very
important when you want to configure the
alert policy in the next steps to talk
about alignment it's best to describe
how an alert policy is actually
evaluated so here is a set of raw set of
data we picked an alignment period of
five minutes what does that mean it
means take all the points in the five
minute window in this case calculate the
mean which is two then
alerting kicks in we set the threshold
which is 13 and then we decided duration
which is three minutes the way the
threshold works is it says are these
points indicative of deal condition
being active then the duration says is
the condition active for three
in this case none of the points indicate
that the condition is active so the
alert doesn't fire alerting is real-time
so then we move to the next minute and
we say over this 5-minute window what is
the query return the query returns a
different value still below the
threshold and when it returns the
different value then we applied the
duration window a second time and we say
none of the points are above threshold
alert doesn't fire
we've repeat again and again until
there's a point above the threshold be
alert however still doesn't fire
duration is telling you over the whole
three minutes are all the points all the
queries above the threshold it's not the
case until here now all three points are
above the threshold and the alert fires
your phone goes off you get an email or
any one of your other notification
channels that are configured or fired
the alert will continue to be active
it's a real-time system we're continuing
to check that the alert is active until
the alert finally sauce being active the
first time we get a query point that's
below the threshold the alert is now
considered inactive by cloud monitoring
and you will get a result of resolution
notification on any of your notification
channels and that is the end of how an
alert policy is evaluated from here I'll
now send it to Rory to actually
demonstrate some use cases of alerting
and cloud monitoring so the first demo
that we're going to present is creating
an alert query where we'll get into a
lot of the concepts the site you just
mentioned in terms of alignment
filtering aggregation that's it we'll
start by looking at an example
kubernetes cluster here we see the demo
cluster with five different nodes and
several different micro services running
on pods now normally we would recommend
using service monitoring to create SLO
based alerts for monitoring your micro
services running on kubernetes in
production however today we're going to
do just a simple infrastructure based
alert to illustrate some of the concepts
behind alerting so we'll go into cloud
monitoring we select alerting here in
the left nav and let's click create
policy
so let's start by creating an alert
policy that will alert us if the gke
node CPU utilization goes too high we
click add a condition and we'll search
for the kubernetes node resource type
and then let's select CPU allocatable
utilization
once we select that we see a couple of
different options appear here in the
left column filtering lets us reduce the
amount of data returned for a metric by
specifying filter criteria this removes
some data from the chart by excluding
time-series that don't meet that
criteria for example we see here we have
time series for five different nodes but
if we click on filter we can filter down
those available time series by project
ID location node name a bunch of
different options in this case let's
select node name and we could say that
we wanted to filter by all of the nodes
that start with a certain string prefix
like G ke - demo or we could say very
specifically we want to filter and show
only this specific instance ID name as
you can see once we selected the filter
now we only have a single time series
group by works by identifying sets of
time series that all meet some criterion
and then combining or aggregating the
members of those sets together grouping
is done on the basis of resource and
metric labels for example here we go in
and we can group by project IDs location
cluster names user metadata labels
system metadata lots of available
options so in this particular case let's
go ahead and group by location we see
here all of our time series were
replaced by a single time series in a
single location us central one a and
another way that you can kind of
understand this is if we remove the
group by and the aggregator let's go
back here and look at our legend if you
notice here the legend contains
different columns or label label keys so
if we go ahead and select these we see
all these time series
these different label values location
cluster name project ID and cetera
so again group by lets us reduce down to
a single time series or pardon me lets
us reduce down to time series grouped by
a single label value in this case
location aggregation lets us combine
time series by using common functions
sometimes called reducers the available
reducing functions depend on the type of
values the metric captures but they
commonly include choices like Mean Max
min standard deviation assorted
percentile values other kind of
statistical operations when used with
grouping the reducing functions are
applied across all of the selected time
series combining them to a single time
series consisting of mean sum or other
measure as is calculated across all the
time series so when used with grouping
again this function is applied to the
time series within each group so again
just to see how that would work if we
select mean here we're taking the mean
or the average across those five time
series produced by all of our nodes and
here we see a single time series there
or perhaps we will want to look at the
99th percentile which is useful for
latency metrics or you know many other
many other kinds of metrics now we'll go
into Advanced Options here and if you
remember from Syed's demonstration
earlier one of the most important fields
to set for alert policies is the
alignment period so take for example an
alert that you specify where you want to
say alert me if my CPU utilization is
over 90% for 10 minutes if you remember
from Syed's talk the for 10 minutes part
is actually the alignment period that we
want to set what this does is it says
look at the last 10 minutes and take all
the raw points that have been written
for a given time series and then apply
an aligner which in this case it
defaults to a mean aligner so
effectively take all those points
average them and produce a single point
for the last ten minutes that will be
used as part of our
evaluation so we'll go here and we'll
set just an arbitrary threshold so that
we can talk to this a little bit better
but now that we have a threshold we can
see our points have been aligned using
the mean aligner
over the last ten minutes and here is
how the time series are evaluating we
have three of them that are below the
threshold and then two that are above so
now if we scroll down to configuration
we see the next important option which
is this alert condition will trigger if
the default option is if any time series
violates so if we scroll up here we can
see that because there are two above the
threshold this will go ahead and trigger
there are also options for percent of
time series you could say I want 50% of
my time series to be above or below the
threshold 75% whatever you're interested
in you can pick an exact number like two
of my time series three of my time
series or you can say all of them have
to be above or the above or below the
threshold for the condition to trigger
now for the condition we can say that we
want these time series to be above or
below the threshold we can say that we
want them to be changing by a certain
percentage so for perhaps in a dynamic
environment I want to be alerted if my
latency increases by 90% or 100%
something like that or if in a
steady-state environment if something
decreases by a certain percentage in a
short amount of time lastly there's also
an option for absence alerts but we'll
talk about that in another demo lastly
this for option refers to the duration
setting that Sayyid also spoke to you in
his demonstration for most people for
threshold based alerts we recommend
setting the value here to the most
recent value such that when the time
series go above or below the threshold
you are alerted immediately now if you'd
like to use duration or a duration value
to reduce false positives you can do
that for example we could say that the
time series must
across the threshold for and must remain
above the threshold or remain in
violation for a three minute period for
the electric trigger which will which
will again reduce false positives but
also has the risk of making your alert
be less likely to fire based on the
shape of your data and we'll have a
demonstration later that illustrates
that point so now let's go ahead and
save our condition will also add a
notification channel so that when our
alert fires we can be notified on email
slack pager duty etc so we'll go ahead
and say that we want an email to be sent
to you food example.com and lastly we'll
put in some documentation that explains
to the person on-call how they might
attempt to remediate the issue caused by
the alert so we might say that they
should check the database locks they
should check the amount of allocatable
CPU quota for the pods etc now we'll go
ahead and save this policy now we see a
graph here again of our time series we
also see incidents that will this is
where once the alert starts firing
incidents will appear now we can go
ahead to see what that looks like we can
go into our list of existing incidents
we'll select one of them and here we see
in the message field it tells us exactly
what resource this particular gke node
caused the alert to trigger based on a
certain time series value over our
threshold we can see the graph here of
all of our nodes so that we can easily
compare the node in violation to the
performance of the other nodes and we
see some labels here that help us again
zero down and two and figure out what
the exact resources that's causing our
issue lastly we can also link out
directly to logs and other ops
management tools that help us figure out
what the root cause of the problem is
and to remediate the issue for a second
demo we're going to talk about absence
alerts and how they differ slightly from
threshold based alerts to illustrate the
concepts behind absence alerts let's go
ahead and
select a log based metric that we
created from one of our App Engine apps
and in this example the App Engine app
was spun up at this point in time it
started to write logs and then we
disabled the app at which point it
stopped writing logs as you can see here
this graph is expressed as a rate which
is why it's spiky it's how frequently
the log is being written in our case for
an absence alert we we really don't care
about the rate we want to just see the
count or the number of time series
points that were written for the log
based metric so in this case we will
apply a count aligner which gives us a
nice smooth line here again we have kind
of a step function we see missing data
or absent data here here is metric data
and then it goes absent again right here
in order to create an absence alert for
this metric what you want to do is focus
on the bottom you want to say instead of
condition is above you say is absent
then the threshold will go away and
underneath the four you have the amount
of minutes that you actually worry about
this metric being absent before your
phone goes off or before you get another
type of communication in this case we'll
choose 10 minutes and the last thing
here is to clicking again on show
Advanced Options you'll note that if you
want to a granade so for example you
don't care that this log space metric is
absent for any specific custom label but
you care that the metric doesn't exist
at all you may want to pick an
aggregator when that happens you will
need to pick an aligner like count for
alignment period we suggest just picking
one minute that way you don't have to
think about it you can focus on the
important parameter which is the amount
of time that the metric is absent in our
third demo we'll discuss how alignment
period in duration interact with each
other and how it affects whether or not
you are
Erbs fire reliable to further illustrate
the differences between alignment period
in duration let's look at an example
here where we're starting to see a real
spiky increase in network traffic we've
selected the received bytes metric for
our GCE vm instance we see over here are
received by count which is spiking up
and down over time we've also filtered
this down to the traffic sent to a very
specific VM the demo VM and so we've
gone down here and said we want to be
alerted if the time series values are
above this threshold for an amount of
time let's say we want to be alerted if
it's above the threshold for 10 minutes
now
naively this might make sense but will
this alert fire every time the line here
on the graph crosses the threshold and
the answer is No based on the
demonstration earlier we know that we
care about the 10 minute summary of
bytes received to do that we should not
change this field in the 4 field instead
we should go to Advanced Options pick an
alignment period of 10 minutes and then
pick a statistic that we like in this
case rate over 10 minutes sounds
reasonable this is the average bytes
received per second over every 10 minute
window you can see that the curve is
smoother better representing the fact
that you care about a 10 minute average
after this for the 4 field which was it
10 minutes the best thing to do is to
set this two most recent value that way
every time this smooth line goes above
the threshold your alert will fire and
your alert will not flap because
remember you have a smooth curve it's
going to take some effort for that curve
to come back down so now that we have
correctly set the alignment period and
duration values let's go ahead and save
this condition and one other thing that
we want to illustrate is the ability to
add multiple conditions to an alert
policy when we want to detect the ping
storm is happening we're interested not
only in the receive
by its for one VM for our demo VM but
we're actually interested in the
behavior of another VM so let's go ahead
and look at our GCE instances and in
this case we're interested in CPU
utilization for a different VM this one
by the name of instance one so now we
see that now that we've filtered down to
this particular instance we see here
that instance one CPU utilization has
been pegged at 100% for quite some time
now so we might want to say that if our
CPU utilization is over 90% for a 10
minute alignment period then alert us
when the most recent value crosses the
threshold and we'll go ahead and click
Add there you see now that we've added
two conditions we have another option
that the policy will trigger when it
defaults to any condition is met so if
either of these conditions trigger
you'll receive an alert you also have
the option to say if all conditions are
met so both would have to both
conditions would have to be true and
then lastly in our case we will select
all conditions are met even for
different resources free for each
condition so if you remember in our case
the first condition was filtered down to
the instance ID demo and the second
condition was filtered or predicated on
the instance ID instance 1 so this has
been an example that not only
illustrates both the interrelationship
between alignment and duration but also
how you would combine multiple
conditions within your alert policy and
that is it for our intro to alerting and
cloud monitoring thanks for listening
and have a nice day